the girag an experience we were talking
about earlier I I really am happy that
the comedy scene is slowly getting
braver with jokes it seems like it's a
weird thing because in the 80s it was a
like the cool thing to be a liberal and
I'm Democrat and Republicans they just
they're just Christians they have Family
Values then want to get high or go to
heavy metal concerts [ __ ] Republicans
but as you get older and you have kids
and I don't know what happened I don't
know what happened but it seems like now
the cool kids are Republicans well do
you know the expression show me a young
man who's not a liberal and I'll show
you a man with no heart show me an old
man who's not conservative and I'll show
you a man with no brain you know there's
certain aspects of me that have become
more conservatives I've got older I've
like appreciate hard work more I
understand like the mental pitfalls
involved in self-pity and a lot of
values man number one thing cuz when I
grew up there were no family valleys and
I thought Family Values is a way to
control you they're trying to control
you with the family values in Christ
yeah and the older you get you're like
if I was a [ __ ] idiot of course it's
all about family
you gotta have values a dude with no
values is a dude you can't trust worth
the [ __ ] is trust it's also when you
have something to lose you realize that
everybody has something to lose and it
puts you in like you commiserate with
all the other people that also have
families you all y'all feel that's one
thing when you go to like family
gatherings and everyone's got their kids
like you feel about their kids the way
you feel about your kids like you want
to look at what's going near the stairs
like you don't this is what communities
and tribes used to be like yeah like we
gravitate towards that it's good for
everybody
yeah it's a you know what I used to
think growing up that giving in to your
desires was like that's your right it's
my right if I'm horny I'm gonna [ __ ] if
I wanted party I'm gonna drink and these
[ __ ] right-wing people from Alabama
they're trying to throw Jesus down my
throat and trying to push you know push
their family values and but I swear now
dude I'm not
Republican I'm not claiming Republican
at all or anything but I get it now I
get it
cuz I have a kid and there's no way
anybody is gonna convince me that
because some [ __ ] kid with pink hair
all looped up on pharmaceuticals shoots
up a mall that it makes sense that I
give up my guns and I can't protect my
family these are long complex plane that
to me to get in the weeds if we branch
off in all these different directions
but I know what you're saying is like as
you get older especially when you have
family but but it's made me is it's made
me way more compassionate and way more
understanding
[Applause]